Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier.
And welcome to "Golfing Over It with Alva Mah-ho"
Now this is a shameless rip.
I will be the first to admit it.  It is probably...
an absolute shameless rip or copy...
of "Getting Over It with Bennett Foddy."
Even the name suggests that it is trying to emulate it as closely as possible.
Now, does that mean...that that matters?
Depends on who you ask
but what does matter is people probably do say
or think or are sure of that this game...is infuriating
but probably not for the same reasons, considering
I'm going to be golfing up a mountain instead of
not getting up a mountain at all and screaming in rage.
Don't expect me to get super duper angry on this one.
I'm probably going to stay as calm as possible because I doubt that I'm actually going to be taking this
so seriously that it actually makes me mad, but we will see upon the first...
whatever I'm doing...
Mmm...I hate that already.
ok, that's not so bad.
I've seen videos of this, not the top of it, but you can hit it...
Ah, you can hit it while it's in midair which... is probably not gonna be the most considerably good thing?
ehh
Okay...
So you can hit it when it-
Oh my God, it is a--
mmh
MMH
mh
eeEH
Right, okay..
You don't know that about me and I don't know that about you.
So don't assume anything of me and I won't assume anything of you.
Can I already say that I don't like --
--your voice!
Sounds like you're too close in my ear for my comfort...
Uh-huh
Okay so, so far not so bad...
It-It's really not the worst thing I have ever done in the world.
Oh..
Okay...
Alright, sure whatever you say.
You're not Bennett Foddy and frankly that's a good thing.
Okay...
[voice crack] Not so bad, LEEEGHNUUUAAH not so ba--
ohh...
Not so bad as far as I can say...
It does that same thing with the controls where the um...
Oh boy...
Do I have to get on top of the shovel to be able to get up here?
ah th-there's no way in hell that I'm gonna be able to do that...
Oh bo- Oh no...
Oh no..
Ahhh!
So the longer you...
the longer you hold it after you've been hit...
the bigger the circle charges...
Uh-oh
HHHOOoOoOoOoOH!
Whoa..
Hey, not so bad. Not so bad!
Not-naaa-ooo
That's...that's worse
hup
Stop...STOP
yeah...
uh-oh
[exhales] ohhhh
no-- nOOOOOOOOOO!!
*sigh*
[through teeth] Uh-huh...Okay
Uh-huh...
eeeeEEEH
*sigh*
[laugh] huh...heh
Yeah
li- oh no
Little bit of both, buddy!
Little bit of both!
Also, it's an interesting perspective j-
Ah fucking hell
It's an interesting perspective just to h-
AAaaaoookay
INTERESTING PERSPECTIVE JUST TO HAVE LIKE
the...the... the dialogue mimic the EXACT dialogue from the beginning of the...
Getting Over It with Bennett Fooboo
It's not THAT bad.
Like, I get it
This...this beginning is gonna be rough for me because I'm learning...
the capabilities of what I can do
But that DOESN'T me-
Oh fuck you
That doesn't mean that it's
bughh
That doesn't mean
Oooh fuck you
That doesn't mean that it's bad.
It just me-
Ohh fuck you
It just means that it's annoying
There we go
Just light taps.
Sometimes you need a hard tap!
Sometimes you just need a light, itty-bitty tap.
There ya...
nnnnNNNNNNOOOOOOO!!!!!
There ya go.
Yeah just the lightest of
TOOches.
Hup!
Annnd get up there.
Oh yeah.
See how....
gooOOOood?
Nooooo....
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
[rage building]
I'm learning it though!
I am, in fact, learning it!
Cause it's getting better.
It's the double - the double - maybe there's a triple hit possible
Do you think that's a thing?
I mean, as long as it's white, right?
HOOO yes! Yes baby, you can!
No, NOT...LIKE that! Ohh my G-, ohh my God.
Heyyyy, okay! We made it back up here, finally.
HOPPAH! okay, alright.
But it's okay cause we're trying to make it up here
No...
Very close
Getting- ugh, getting better... I just can't bounce there too hard.
A-HA, the triple jump!
OH BABY, A TRIPLE!!
Let me just try to get up on this racket...
Just a oh... just a little up on the racket is all I really need.
Because if can get up on the racket, that's where I probably should be?
If I wanted to make the jump more precisely?
Oh yeah, okay, so when we go here
HOOP!
No, I di- OAOAOAOAAAOAH!
Nailed it.
Okay, I almost did the exact same thing that I did last time, but not this time!
Because I'm not an idiot
ooohaaah...
Okay... this is... this is fun
[gasp of imminent death]
Very scary!
Okay... HUP, HOPAAH Yeah, yeah, yeeeaaahh!
Okay.
Hup, boink!
don't donk
D'OHHHH!
NICE HAIR
Nice anime hair.
[Horsune Miku according to the Steam Trading Cards]
hoop! No! Aaah! Oh my GAAHD!
You're very scary.
hup, WHAP, NO! NO!
-sigh of relief-
hup
No no NO NO NO NO NO NOO!
[last vestige of joy leaving Mark's body]
[exhale]
[grumpled exhale]
[raspy exhale] haaaa
[exhale] Oh...
[blows frustrated raspberries]
[even more frustrated raspberries]
No, no, no, no, NO!
Oh my God...
Nononono no no no NO!
This is gonna be a son of a bitch.
And I agree with that! The controls, you know, it's- it's- it's not unknowable
it's- it's predictable, it is- he is absolutely right; you just gotta tooch it with the right scooch
and you've got magic happening
you've got magic shooting out of your ball
You just need to- ookay- you just need to toochy-scootch it just the right way.
Okay, I got to scoochy-tooch up there, I gotta toochy-scooch UP there
I gotta toochy-scooch up there
I've got- nooo
I've got to toochy-scooch UUUP THERE
I'VE GOT TO TOOCHY-SCOOCH up there.
no, to...
Ah, good, perfect tooch
WAH!
HEY, look at me.
boink, yeeh-AAaaww, scawy, scawy, scawy
hup! no...
HO MY GOD, I'm on the eagle!
I just gotta get on the L'PHANT!
Oh my God, no no no no no no NO NO
Okay, we're fine.
Hup!
No, no, NOOOO!
Oh, SHUT the FUCK up!
Oh, fuck off.
Somehow, he's more annoying.
I don't know how he's managed to do it, but somehow he's wa-- he's been able to come up with a way of talking to me
that's just even more infuriating than Bennett Fotty ever could've been.
Phew!
The act of pulling it back each time, after each subsequent one, is q u i t e  d i f f i c u l t
'cause it's like I don't pull enough
Maybe I don't need to pull it much at all
Oh, I guess I don't
Right, it's not about pulling
Yeah, okay, it's not about how hard you pull, right?
Yeah, it's not. I was mislead into thinking that you'd have to pull it back harder.
It's only based in time.
Ye- NO, NO, NO, YES, YES, YES
Oh, this is like "Golf with Your Friends" all over again except it's even worse
No, NOoooh my God
No!
Eugh!
No, no, NO!
God fuck-a-ducky dammit!
What's over here, is there anything over here?
Just a goddamn tree?
Is that what it is? Is that what we're dealing with?
What happens if I go over the goddamn tree, huh?
-groan-
Why do I want to go up this tree? I'm not sure.
Hup!
What is this? What is- what is- what the fuck is this?
What is this? What am I looking at?
Some kind of giant- oh, it's like a tornado-dick, whatever it is, I don't care
Alright
Let's go back up, let's go back up the other way yay ya--
The thing is, like, it's like easy to- just like in golf
It's very easy to do
OhhhhUUUUUUUUN
NNNNECESSARY
HUUUMMM
MOVEMENT
force
Force is the word I was looking for.
It's very easy
to apply
unnecessary force
Ah!
No!
Nooo...
okay...
It's not so bad. It's not as bad as going ALL the way down
Cuz', I mean, I can predictably get--
ba-- No!
NO!
NOOO!!
GOD
FUCK-A-DUCKING
F-- I DIDNT DO ANY--
RIGHT CLICK GOES TO THAT?
Okay...
easy shot
Yeah, just gotta FALL in the pocket...
that's all I gotta do
just like on that elephant!
I just gotta not over-shoot it!
FALL in the tusks...
like a gentle...
...summer breeze
and now i just gotta fall in the tail!
eAsY
auUUUGH
-orst thing i ever-- oh-- even better!
even-- look! they're touching!
*gasp*
they're touching
I went too far...
oh...
I love all of your HAIR
It's so [deep voice] preeeetty...
even YOU, Naruto
oH MY GOD
WHERE AM I-
Oh...
I don't like the underwater-ness of this
please tell me that I can't-
please tell me that, on a rare occasion, I wont be falling through the little gap there...
that's something that I would [not?] like VERY much
okay, just gOTTA GET--
in the TOUCHIE SCOOTCHES
Yeah
ohh sooo saaaafe
DorAaAaAaAaAah
ononoNONO OKAY ALRIGHT I WAS CAUGHT
NO! oh my God...okay
I was caught...there we go
just gotta...yeeahh.
like a- like a suMMER BREEeEeeEze
in it- oh God I'm in it...
okay. OH there's the... -chuckles-  I guess this is land and sea level and that's...
HEE..okay. GETTING GOOD! Made a lot of progress in a very sh-VEH!
-inhales- nnooooOOOOOooo...very short amount of time..
eeh, ooh, ooh, OOH, OOH, OOH, WHY are you still MOVING...???
-realizing his future- okay let's do this again very...
CAAALM- euueugh why did you go that way?
Oh the little divet rivet on the boat. That's fun that that is there
Okay...alright...
Easy peasie...
There. NOOO NOOO WHERE ARE YOU GOOOohhh..
shut your--
You don't know that.
I don't even care about the top of the mountain
I'm n- I AM just playing
I am not, I am not concerned about getting to the top of the mountain
That's NOT my concern.
Do you think that's my concern?
My concern is trying to beat this game with my sanity intact!
nnn-why?
No No No
HYEEAAYY
Back on the horse again [sarcastic Ha Ha Ha]
I'm sure that's what it's really supposed to be
Ooooo
ooohhhhh...
Any fucking day now-ANY FUCKING
D̹ͪ̄͛̈́̍͌̂̿A͈̱̔̽͊̽̃͛ͥ͢͞Y̵̤̯͉͍̽ͪ̀̐ͮ̉ͪ͋̈́̀ ͔͉̞̻̐̏́̍ͬ̓ͥ͝͞N̳͈̠̥̬̒ͥ̓̋̽͝͞O̵͇̜̠̣̞͕͔͋̾̈́ͥ͟W̷̴̷̱̭̦̮̗̱̤ͪͯ͊!̴̞͈͉̘̠͓̥̒́
No no no no no NOOOO WHY
WOULD YOU DO
THAT JUST
STOP ROLLING
fucking hell...
d-ffff, fucking
S͈̜͍͓̫̒̏͛̍ͮ͐ͭ̽ͣ͘͟Ṭ̰̼̭̗̰͍̳̋͑̈́ͥ̌ͯ̕͡ͅO̐ͨͧ̽̏͛̐͌͝͏̣͖̺̼̤P̢̘̖͍̞̱͚̦̓̂̓̀̇̃!̸̿ͧ҉̦̦̪͉͉͈͡ͅ
Oh my God, if you
I sw- I swear to FUCKING
[pounds table to emphasize]
OH MY GOD! Are you FUCKING KIDDING ME?!
OH MY GOD!!
Ohh my God, I can't get up this now.
A- WH- I can't get up THIS! THIS! I can't get up THIS?
oh my God
It doesn't matter what I do it's light or hard
I can't get up THIS.
This ALWAYS HAPPENS, every single FUCKING time
I play ANY SORT OF DIFFICULT G-ANY GAME, PERIOD,
If I do any FUCKING GAME
It starts out tooootally fine
I'm fine everything's--
Everything starts out totally fucking fine
And then for some reason
skill just goes completely out the window
Nice x3
Okay, I'm back in the saddle-Oh
[quiet panic]
Oh stop again
I'm baaaack in the saddle again
Among my pEEople
[referencing the E meme, are we?]
That's so scary
I know that's a safe spot but I don't trust that to always be a safe spot
For some reason
For some reason, cause I know how gaaaames
like to dick
I have this weird feeling that it's gonna suddenly decide on a random chAAA
AAHHH-AHHH-AAANCE
*intense heartbeat*
Yes.
Right in the pocket
*le gasp*
*le exhale*
Okay
Just like that
Baby, just *like* thaaat, CAREFUL
Careful now, care-CAREFUL!
CAREFUL NOW!
CAREFUL Now.
Okay
N-No no no n-okay
Just go a li-- NO, Oh okay
NO PLEEEEEEEAASE.
Let's just go back, I bail.
*le gasp* I BAIL, I BAIL, I BAIL, I BAIL!
[exhales quietly]
OOH!
Yes, there is
I don't care
I really don't care
Oh, I- like I said, I don't care
There's a cannon pointed at her?
Well, then that seems like it's her fault
for living in a- ohhh [laughs]
Well you know I'm gonna touch the cannon
I'm- I'm really gonna tooch that cannon
So-uh, Sorry! Sorry Alvatross
[boom]
Oooh
Well, poor Alvatross
Poor Alvie
ALVIEEEE
Uh, well, that's too bad
[F to pay respects]
That looks like it could be bad
The spikes there look like bad news bears
aaaaah
nooookay
ah, ok
I don't know, man
Uh-huh
Uh-h-HOHOHOHO-AH, AH!
NOOO
N O
I'm in unquestionably uncomf-territory right now
And I don't l- do I have to like
yee, that seems scary
That seems really scary, but I-I'll-- Noo-ah
AHHHH
[almost relief] AAaah
[three exhaled "ah"]
I'm not cut out for this
I'm--NOOOOOOO
NOOOO
[happiness dying]
NOOOOOOOO
[soul dying]
[fast propeller spinning sound]
Wha-
[backwards whistle "eeeewwwmmp"]
Thank you?
Was that the ghost of Alvarez?
You came to save mEEE
Okay, I don't kn- No no no no.
WHY?!
AHHHHHH
No
Okay let's just scoot-yeah
You know, let's just go right there, that's perfectly fine
NononononoNo
IT WON'T SAVE ME TWICE!
NOOOO, I WAS FINE!!
How did that happen?
I told you those spikes were bad news
Okay,  gently, ooh yeah
NO NO NO NOOOO
Uh- Noooo Noooo
uhnonono
Thank you
Thank you for that
ugh, fffffffFFFFF
FOR FUCK SAA-HA-HA-AAKE!
No, No, that 's gonna go all the way DOWN
GOOD FUCKING GOOOODDDD!!
GOOD FUCKING GAAA-
That's going all the way
I can't get on this horse anymore
I just can't, I can't get on the horse again
For some reason I can't get on the horse
I remember before I was able to get on the horse totally fine
But somehow, that all gonna- this is gonna roll for fuckin' ever
Man, there's, there's-there's a legitimate reason why I can't
do rage games.
Is it, like it, it doesn't just make me angry
It makes me *le breathe* so fucking miserable
It's not just anger, it's just misery
It's pain, it's PAINFUL for me to do this
It's an itchy all-over-body feeling
to do these games
it just makes everything uncomfortable
And then for hours, for HOURS, and HOURS and hours afterwards
I can't do anything
And the worst part is
Because I don't like to give up
Because I don't ever like to give up
I just keep fucking doing it
it's a vicious cycle that feeds in and it
it's NOT something that I do because
HOOOOOHHHH
FUCK YAY! A rage game, people can laugh at me being angry
FUCK THAT! When have I ever done anything like that
for YOUR benefit?!
It's just, it's a fuckin'-- oh I..
*le sigh*
[fast hearbeat over sine tone]
I wanna be very fucking clear about this
This is not about you
This is NOT about you
This is not about you at all
This is nnNOTHING to do with you
This is NOT a GODDAMN thing to do with you
I'm the one who wants to beat it
I am the one who wants to make progress
I am the ONE who is UPSET because I AM LEARNING
ABOUT THIS GAME, and it's not-
*le sigh*
this fuckin...
Somehow we've made it back up here
Not a hundred percent sure how
But I'm not gonna question it
in the corner
pocket
No, no please
PLEASE, OH MY GAAAWD
Alright, let's just do this nice and easy style
No pressure, no pressure, no pressure
This is not
that
difficult
Okay, that's fine
Nooo pressure, no pressure, no pressure
No nonono
NO NO OH MY GAAWD
OOOHHHH- Good thing I went for the
the extra PAH-wer
[quietly] ok...
Cause I don't understand why those were bi-UH
Eh, NO NAH
Some of those shots were bigger but they were real quick
and I-I-I'm not sure I'm fahh- NO
NO! NO!
What the FUCK?!
hohhh ♫thank you, I guess♫
[in the style of Jingle Bells]
♫Thank you, I guess♫
♫Thank you, I guess, I guess.♫
Hokay
No
NAHH! NO! NO! GOD FUCKING DAMMIT!
OOHHH, NNNN
N͇̺͌ͤͩͮ̅̉̆̈́̓͟͞O̵̳͎̾ͩͩ͛̈͘O̧͍̓̌̅Ǫ̝̰̳̝̮̇̉ͬ̂ͥ̾ͨ̔̒͢ͅ
No no no no no--oh my Goooddd
NO NO NOOO GAWD-
Ugh, I can't do this
Oh nope- that's, that's all the way, that's all the way, that's-
*le breathing*
News update: It stopped making me angry because I just don't care anymore
And what the fuck does it matter
We're all gonna die anyway, so...
Fuckin' love this
This is my favorite thing to do
Yeah
This is how I wanted to spend my day
Yep, there we go
Oh yeah, no
This is great
Mkay
hit the ceiling
No
Here we go again,
YAAAAAAAY, YAAAAY, YAY, YAY, WOOOO
CAN YOU BELIEVE HOW MUCH FUN I'M HAVING?!
WHOA WHOA WHOA
SOMEONE STOP ME, SOMEONE CALL THE FUN POLICE!
I'M JUST HAVING TOO MUCH OF A GOOD THIIING!
Ohh BOYYY
I'M SO HAPPY TO BE ALIIIIVE!
Oh man, I'm glad I was born in this year where this game was made
and I get to plaaayy it.
Can you [lisp]see how lucky I am?
YAyyyy
YAYYY OH BOY YAAAYYYYY YAA--
WAHOOOO
NOW I KNOW WHY MARIO SHOUTS WAHOO!
There we go, just bypass the horse.
Just completely.... noo.
Nevermind
Ohh- Again!
OHHHH
WELL GREAT. GREAT GREAT GREAT GREAT.
FUCKING GREAT.
A- gu-gu-gain.
A-OHHH WELL.
JUST S- DONT EVEN BOTHER, DONT EVEN BOTHER.
It doesn't fucking matter.
Every-oh I did it...again.
ok, good
WHY ARE YOU
ohh my God, you don't release.
Sometimes it just doesn't relEEEASE.
It just doesn't
It didn't see- it didn't there!
It didn't release it! Why didn't you release it?
Stop-stopp.
Just st- oh NO, NOOO! NOOO-HO-HOOOO!
nnnooaww
There, that's not bad.
That's pretty good, actually.
Okay
Alright.
I don't know what it wants from me, but we've made forward progress, which is a God...damn delight.
Oh, now you're gonna start talking to me, huh?
Ok, which way am I going here?
Am I tryin' to get in the little scootch?
nnugh, tiny, tiny hit, tiny hit, tiny hit...
[gasp] no...
no....no...
WHA?
Ok, I just completely bypassed it 'cause I didn't wanna deal with it.
ok, easy enough... Just gotta get in the buttcrack of the planets here.
Looks like we can actually AVOID IT! Which is nice.
Don't know what's up with the DNA.
You know what? This looks like it's going to be a SON of a bitch. HOW...in THE hell?
Oh I see, we're just supposed to go around it, we're not supposed to be looking at it. ok.
I don't know what th- oh that's the inner workings of a cell, ok.
I have a funny feeling it's getting to dicey moments, but I wanna try to get up on that cell, and I know I can do that.
Yep, I knew I could do it.
Easy enough.
This actually isn't all that hard.
This actually is surprisingly easy.
nnnnnnn don't prove me wrong.
'kay, I just gotta...
there's, there's...
whooooa, too much, too much, too- scootch too much.
NoooOOOO OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD!
[inhale of imminent death]
okay...
I gotta be careful or I'm-I'm liable to lose everything if I get cocky...
Which I have a habit of doing at the worst of times
okay...
Alright. That's easy enough.
I'm on a skellington, which is nice.
I don't know where I am in the grand scheme-- do you have hair as well?
Ohh you dooo, you do. And a friend.
A PART of a friend anyway...
Alright, so this isn't the worst thing in the world.
oh no, nonononono, ohh nonono...
No nonono
Not as much as you think.
No, ohh hhh
[sigh of great relief]
i
don't care
what you have to say
philosophically-wise.
So that- left is harder? And right is easier?
Well that's gotta be a gadamn trick!
oh well, speaking of "tricks"
So I'm gonna go the harder path, just because I'm pretty sure that's what they would want...
...to send you down anyway. So...
...kudos to me, I guess.
Se-
[music starts up]
See, I d- oh...
Is this it?
No! Ok, you know what?
NOT PLAYING THAT FUCKING GAME!
You know what? You wanna play disappearing blocks with me?
Fuck you
Fuuuuck you in eeeevery poooosssible way, shape, and form.
Hey, I've triggered the music though, so that's nice I- I guess.
Yeah, screw that shit.
Not goin' there.
Not doin' that, not goin' there,
not doin' that, not goin' there.
oh no...oh boy, ok be careful with this one
Easy enough.
These, these, these blocks seem slanted..?
Which, generally, means that I would roll...
...off either side. They don't seem straight up flat.
Just a cursory observation tells me that if I land on it wrong, I'm probably going to, you know...
...end up dying.
No, nO NO NOO NAAAUGH, come on!
ohhh fuck meee
uh-oh. No- well, this is...
[exhale] fffff...
Welcome to the new Hell.
Just a short stop away from the old Hell.
No, a- why did I do that? I don't know. I have no idea why I do anything in this game.
I don't even know why I'm still playing this fucking game.
No, fucking come-
I don't- this is this- this is what you save me at? This is- this is, d'okay, whatever, you know what? Thank you, I guess.
Ok, and you're not gonna- it's- which direction are you gonna go in? ok, that's fair.
It bugs if you click it too fast, which is sssssoooo fucking great.
Noo... [exhales]
oh...
mother...
fffffffff
fucking cr-
You didn't go, which way are you gonna go?
ohhh my GAAAWD!
nope, okay...
oh OH oh...
[Mark's eyes of deadness]
[eeewwwmmmp]
wow
You know what? I am grateful for that.
But I was actually looking forward to just...being able to say goodbye to this game.
I really was, so, frankly, you didn't really save me from anything.
You just made me have to keep--
[scoffs] which direction are we gonna go in?
Yep, that's what I FUCKING THOUGHT, YOU FUCKING BUGGY PIECE OF SHIT!
Thought I was gonna be able to say goodbye and that would've been really great because I wanted to go on with my life, but no, I'm still fucking playing.
Give me a fucking excuse to stop.
This sssssstupid, asinine game.
oKAY!
I don't know where we are!
And I don't know why!
But I'm just gonna count my blessings and assume that I'm getting close to the end
because I have got to-
HEY, MOON!
You gonna open your eye? When I least suspect it?
Probably
yeah woow, good yay, I can go high, I know to do the trick, yep I sure do.
I suuuuuuure as shit do
wow, that was...
I- even I didn't think I was gonna make that.
OH GOOD, GOLF A- nooo that's not how we do it here
Gawd-fucking-dammit, this is where
it's gonna get real dicey, isn't it?
Yep, okay. Wow, I'm here, what is here?
Why does this matter?
[sarcastic] wow
thank you
That sounds sarcastic!
Sounds reeeeaallly sarcastic, and I don't appreciate the sarcasm...
nope, this is not what I wanted.
ok, I'll take it.
don't- [sigh]
motherfucker
I HATE YOU
Alright, what have we got here?
Are we- is this actually the end or is this just a trick?
Is this at- is this the end, is- what is this?
What is this? "How're you gonna screw me over?" is the only question I have in my mind.
OH
What happens if I go OVER it?
ok, or you're not even- you're not even gonna give me the chance. ok, I WANTED [sigh]
ah whatever. I don't think you can get over it and frankly I don't care.
Alright.
I didn't even see what my stats were, because I was trying to do something else, but OH WELL!
I'M DONE!
YEEEEEEYYYY
WAAHHHOOOOO
WAAAAAOOOOWWWWEEEE
[smack, smack, smack, smack]
An hour and thirty six minutes.
Two thousand, eight hundred and ninety-eight hits.
I started getting really good at the game.
I really did, I started getting good at that game.
I don't like that.
I don't like that I'm good at this game.
But that's fine. Yeah, it really was, it was one of those situations where...
I was playing,
I got mad and frustrated and then, like, something just dropped out of me and I realized I just didn't care.
I didn't care, I didn't care, I didn't wanna beat it.
And I felt a sense of calm as I was just trying to get through the fucking game.
But I did it! :)
And I did it.
And the thing is, it's not a bad game. uh it's not "bad," it's...
I dunno, it's- it's obviously derivative, because it was obviously inspired by "Getting Over It"
So, inherently, it gets some points deducted a less-than-original idea.
But the golfing aspect of it does bring some different difficulty to it
even if the mechanics are still...kinda...bullshit.
But! THAT IS THAT!
I DON'T LIKE IT, I DON'T LIKE ANYTHING ABOUT IT, I HATE THIS GAME WITH A FIERY BURNING PASSION
AND THAT IS all I have to say about that.
So thank you, everybody, for watching!
Let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below.
If you didn't know, I am going on tour in Amsterdam in July
and there are just some tickets left, so go to
and check 'em out for yourself!
Also...
in November...
we're coming to Australia.
First show's in New Zealand, I believe. Go to
TOUR.MARKIPLIER.COM
or click the link in the description below and you can see it for yourself.
So thank you again.
And as ALWAYS...
I will see you...
in the next video.
BUH-BYYYEEEE!